we're here we're in person i know
this is so exciting i thought at the
last minute they would you know pull it
out and say we couldn't so this is so
nice
okay so everyone is obsessed with white
lotus
it has been renewed but we're hearing
it's gonna be like a complete turnover a
whole another cast
i hope not but i have heard that yeah
and i
i have heard that but you know what you
never know
and um and and even so i mean imagine
what mike white can write the second
time around so even i mean i'll watch it
even if i'm not in it i love it i love
it okay so listen we hear that mindy is
fast at work with this script for season
for uh legally blind three yeah have you
heard anything i know you know i was
hoping tonight someone could fill me in
because i haven't heard anything i mean
i hear you know every week i get like a
little text or something going like it's
happening or whatever like and then uh
and then and then i don't hear anything
again
we got to get something going we need
y'all back we need l back we need y'all
back oh i know i know rhys has a lot
going on but um yeah i hope she
yeah i hope it happens you are also in
shotgun wedding with j.lo and josh
demelle shooting that what was that
experience
uh it was very hot
um they're very hot they're they're uh
they're a really good combination and um
um
yeah i mean look i had some really good
times there and um it was really fun to
shoot that well you always give us an
iconic scene or ten so do we have an
iconic scene in this movie
well let's see um
i don't know if it made it in but um
um
well i don't know i don't have to spoil
it maybe
but um
i don't know if i can can i tell you you
can give a hint yeah you can tell it's
just me i'm good at keeping secrets all
right well parts of it are really scary
there we go i'm not scary in it but
some other people are who is this dress
tonight uh this is christian siriano oh
come on christian yes can you give me
christopher john rogers
darling yes i love it thank you jennifer